نعود المشاهدين الى الخبر العاجل الذي
بدانا به ناشرتنا اذ قال مراسل الجزيره ان
صافرات الانذار تدوي في مستوطنات غلاف غزه
من جهه قال الناطق باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي
انه تم تفعيل صافيرات انذار في مستوطنه
نحل العوز شرقي قطاع غزه هذا وقالت وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه ان قذيفه واحده سقطت في
منطقه مفتوحه خارج المستوطنه
للمزيد من المعلومات معنى من رام الله
مراسله الجزيره جيفارا البوديري جيفارا ما
الذي يتوفر من معلومات وتفاصيل
حتى الان لم يصدر اي شيء جديد اكثر مما
ذكر ولكن الان فقط
الناطق بلسان الجيش الاسرائيلي اكد ان
قذيفه صاروخيه اطلقت من قطاع غزه سقطت في
منطقه مفتوحه في غلاف مستوطنات غزه لم يكن
هناك حاجه حسب بيان الجيش لتفعيل القبه
الحديديه وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه اكدت انه
بالفعل هالي عدد من مناطق مستوطنات غلاف
غزه خاصه نحل عوز وشاعر هانيجيف سمعوا
اصوات سفارات الانذار ولكن لم يسمع اي صوت
لانفجارات اي للسقوط قذائف صاروخيه وهذا
ما يدلل على انه قد يكون بالفعل سقطت
قذيفه واحده اطلقت من قطاع غزه وسقطت في
منطقه مفتوحه والتاكيدات انه لا يوجد هناك
اصابات سواء او في الممتلكات هنا فقط حسن
يجب ان نذكر ان اصلا الاجهزه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه بما فيه الجيش وكافه الاذرع
العسكريه والاستخباريه هي على اهبه
الاستعداد منذ عده ايام خاصه بعد العمليه
الاغتيال التي وقعت يوم الخميس قبل يومين
في مدينه جنين وتم اغتيال اثنين من
المقاومين في كتيبه جنين ومواطنين اخرين
ومسلسل الجرائم الاسرائيليه وايضا هذا ذوي
الصافرات وان كان فقط لقذيفه صاروخيه ينظر
بامكانيه اما اني انفجر الوضع او هو فقط
من احدى الفصائل الفلسطينيه الصغيره شكرا
لك جيفارا البوداري احدثين من رام الله